Trascrizione: Soraya Avinotti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Lo facciamo tutti i giorni:
ognuno di noi, ogni giorno,
fa colazione, pranzo, cena.
Sembra una scelta banale:
ma è una scelta estremamente importante,
per noi e per l'ecosistema in cui viviamo.
Per venire qui oggi,
ho fatto un piccolo calcolo;
e mi son reso conto che lo faremo
circa 80.000 volte nella nostra vita.
Un gesto quotidiano,
che va oltre a una semplice scelta:
sostanzialmente, è un voto.
È un voto al mondo che vorremmo avere,
e nel quale vorremmo vivere
nei prossimi anni.
Nel tempo in cui viviamo,
è diventato estremamente semplice
ordinare un piatto:
basta un click per avere
un piatto come il nostro
sulla nostra tavola.
Dall'altro lato, questo semplice click,
che paragoniamo spesso a un Like
o uno swipe su un social network,
ha un impatto esponenziale nel tempo,
per tutte le conseguenze che comporta.
Anch'io, come tutti voi,
vivo delle mie incoerenze e fatico;
però provo a applicare
le mie conoscenze, il mio impegno
nel provare ad avere e dare un contributo
alla sostenibilità nel lavoro che faccio.
Però, convivo con le mie incoerenze.
Mi definisco un pescetariano:
eppure, in quanto bresciano,
mangio lo spiedo.
E per un bresciano, lo spiedo non è carne:
è stato catartico.
Viaggio, mi piace tantissimo:
qui c'è una mia fotografia in Mongolia.
Mi piace fare trekking,
mi piace fare settimane all'aria aperta
in mezzo al nulla;
eppure, per fare questo viaggio
ho preso n aerei,
per arrivare a destinazione.
Quindi, sono consapevole
di dover convivere
con queste piccole incoerenze.
Ora vi racconto un altro viaggio,
il mio viaggio di esperienza
di imprenditore
all'interno della filiera agroalimentare,
di cui sono consapevole degli impatti
che ha sul nostro ecosistema
in relazione alle azioni
che si fanno in campo,
alla perdita di biodiversità,
al trasporto,
allo smaltimento del packaging,
agli sprechi alimentari connessi.
Sono tutte fonti di emissione,
erosione del suolo,
perdita di biodiversità.
Sempre in questa mia esperienza, però,
ho incontrato tantissimi
piccoli e medi imprenditori
e agricoltori e produttori
vicino a casa nostra, in Italia,
fuori dalle nostre case,
che si stanno impegnando quotidianamente
per dare un piccolo,
ma molto forte contributo
nel loro campo e nella loro attività,
per imprimere un cambiamento.
Una dei principali fattori di impatto
è la perdita di biodiversità.
Si stima che stiamo perdendo
biodiversità specie
a una velocità dieci volte superiore
a quella della soglia "accettabile".
Questo è dovuto, prevalentemente,
perché c'è una forte incentivazione
a premiare solo quelle specie
che sono più, diciamo, sostenibili
da un punto di vista, in questo caso,
economico, per il sistema.
Come si può contrastare
questa perdita di biodiversità?
Questo è un paradosso,
un po' controintuitivo,
è che più mangiamo biodiversità
e più aiutiamo la sua diffusione.
Come dicevo prima,
i sistemi agroalimentari
tendono a incentivare fortemente,
e a premiare fortemente,
le specie che sono
più produttive per il sistema.
In questo caso, ad esempio,
c'è un'azienda agricola, Spadoni,
in provincia di Ravenna,
che ha riscoperto questo suino nero
che vediamo qui nella slide,
che, vedete, che nel 1990 stava sparendo:
erano arrivati ad esserci
solo 18 capi presenti.
Questo suino nero mangia ghiande,
si muove allo stato brado,
quindi ha una produttività molto bassa
rispetto a un "Large white"
che sono i maiali che di solito si vedono:
grandi, bianchi, belli paffutelli.
Questo suino nero ingrassa
solo 300 grammi al giorno,
mentre un Large White
riesce ad arrivare ad un chilo.
E questa scelta di Spadoni
di recuperare questo tipo di suino
e chi poi se ne è nutrito,
gli ha permesso di essere salvato
da una quasi sicura estinzione.
Quindi, fare scelte fuori dal comune
può aiutare a premiare la biodiversità.
Quindi ho presentato -
questa è un'altra che magari molti di voi
penseranno sia un aglio:
invece è una zucca, una zucca estiva.
Anche questa è stata
riscoperta, ultimamente,
proprio da questi agricoltori
che stanno provando a riscoprire
questo tipo di specie rare.
Qui, in questo caso, parlo
di rigenerazione di ecosistemi
di un allevamento di aquacoltura
che c'è che c'è a Gallipoli,
si chiama "Il mare"
è un allevamento biologico
di orate, branzini e ombrine.
In questo allevamento,
c'è una grandissima attenzione
alla rigenerazione dell'ecosistema.
In questo caso,
sono io che mi sono tuffato
all'interno di una di queste vasche.
Questo progetto di Aldo Reo,
che è un imprenditore
meraviglioso della Puglia,
ha voluto lavorare su una rigenerazione
proprio dell'ecosistema
del suo allevamento.
Queste gabbie, che sono posizionate
a un miglio da terra,
e che quindi sfruttano
queste forti correnti
per dare sempre acqua pulita ai sui pesci,
che costantemente nuotano -
ha creato un ecosistema
posando delle rocce al suolo
sotto le gabbie,
ha posizionato delle spugne,
che è una specie in via di estinzione,
per ripristinare l'acqua,
ricreato un ecosistema
intorno a un allevamento di pesci,
quindi provando a rigenerare quelle aree
anche da un punto di vista marino.
Quindi si può allevare pesce,
ma facendolo con grandissima attenzione
all'ecosistema in cui viene fatto.
Ora il passo -
dal mare ritorno sulla terra,
ma per parlare di acqua.
Anche qui volevo portarvi
un altro piccolo esempio,
in quanto riguarda il consumo d'acqua.
Come tutti in questi mesi qua
abbiamo vissuto, ho vissuto raccontandola
e sentendo tanti racconti
di grandissima crisi sulla siccità,
soprattutto - sia durante l'estate,
ma anche questo inverno sta continuando
e sta impattando in maniera molto forte.
Se si pensa che solo il tre percento
dell'acqua disponibile sulla Terra
è acqua dolce;
e di questo tre, il 70% però
è segregato nei ghiacci.
E quindi solo il 30%
è utilizzabile dall'essere umano.
Di questo 30%, il 70%
viene usato in ambito agricolo:
viene usato, ad esempio, per irrigare.
Spesso viene usato
con irrigazioni a pioggia,
che sono altamente inefficienti,
per poter far crescere la pianta.
Con l'irrigazione a pioggia,
il 70% - anche in questo caso -
dell'acqua irrigata viene dispersa,
e solo il 30% va alimentare la pianta.
Anche qui vi ho voluto portare
un altro piccolo esempio
di un'azienda agricola
biologica, in Valtellina:
l'azienda agricola di Franchetti Bio,
che produce mele e kiwi.
Anche lui ha fatto un grande investimento,
da piccolo imprenditore,
e ha creato questo sistema di irrigazione
goccia a goccia per le sue mele,
permettendogli di risparmiare,
e permettendoci a noi di risparmiare
il 90% d'acqua e di irrigazione.
Un'altra piccola provocazione, spunto,
è sull'ultimo miglio.
Cioè: quando facciamo
queste scelte di prodotti,
di cosa mangiamo e dove mangiamo,
è abbastanza controintuitivo anche pensare
che facendo una spesa online
si arriva a consumare il 37% in meno
di emissioni di CO2
rispetto a una spesa
fatta su un canale fisico.
Questo perché?
Perché il sistema
che alimenta una spesa online
è molto più efficiente,
e non implica che noi clienti consumatori
ci rechiamo fisicamente
presso il punto vendita -
punto vendita che deve essere
raffreddato, riscaldato.
Quindi ci sono, anche,
delle modalità di acquisto
che è abbastanza intuitivo pensare
che possano essere
più sostenibili di altre.
Quindi, per finire, vorrei ritornare
sul numero, sulle 80.000.
Sono consapevole, come tutti voi,
che viviamo nella nostra vita
con piccole incoerenze,
che facciamo scelte tutti i giorni
che possono essere anche, diciamo,
difficili da sostenere nel tempo;
ma abbiamo la possibilità di poter avere
un impatto esponenziale nel tempo,
circa 80.000 volte nella nostra vita.
Quindi, proviamoci.
(Applausi)